the best thing about Ted Cruz is that he
has an actual accomplishment to his name
he's done something wait wait let me
guess government shutdown look
Republicans since the middle of the Bush
administration Republican activists have
been trying to get their party and their
party's leadership to do something about
government spending to take seriously
their concerns about the size of
government and Ted Cruz was able to do
something about that in a real and
meaningful way so so far as Republican
base goes has that huge accomplishment -
is it yeah but what about all the people
that would say well the shutdown ended
up costing more money and he actually
accomplished the reverse of what he was
trying to do when Obamacare got passed
anyway but not an easy position to run
on in the general election for sure if
you're appealing to the Republican
primary electorate and again this is an
electorate that's been conditioned by
the Tea Party to mistrust their own
leadership in Washington there really is
no better argument than to say I would
want to shut down the government they
didn't want it to happen but I did it so
is it Ted Cruz candidacy sort of a good
example of sort of how crazy our system
is that a guy like him will do really
well probably in the early primaries
because the tea party is gonna really
back him it goes right to the base but
then as it gets closer to a general
election and the broader people have to
vote for him then he loses some of that
steam right I think it's a it's a it's a
really good example of how conservative
Republican Party has become conservative
in the sense that they're an anti
governing party at their base and Ted
Cruz fits perfectly there it's a
Republican Party now he's allied with
conservatism much more tightly than it
ever was I think that's there's always
going to be in American politics just
because the way the nomination system is
set up you have to appeal to your base
yet the question is what does that base
want to hear this base wanted to hear
shut down the government yeah starve the
beast that's what Ted Cruz said so when
they say things like that you know then
I assume that the Tea Party folks
realized that when he gets to become
powerful he's not going to shut down the
government right I don't think they
assume that at all I think they mistrust
everyone they just yeah I mean you read
and I spend you know a lot of my free
time of course reading the the remnants
of what used to be the blogosphere but
there is a Unruh conservative talk radio
nobody trusts anyone
but people trust crews more than they
trust anyone which is still not that
much but they do and that again is
something that's really really hard to
buy can't buy that with money